hey guys today we're gonna explain the
quirk and philosophy of crust who is the
number six pro hero in Japan and has
likely shed more tears than 99% of the
characters in this series he was first
introduced to us during the pro hero arc
but it wasn't until much later in the
manga that we finally saw the full
capabilities of his power for that
reason this video is split into three
parts with the first part explaining his
abilities without giving away any plot
spoilers and then I'll briefly touch on
what we know if his personality and his
philosophy before moving on to the final
part which is a more spoiler a
discussion about what he's done in this
series so far so if it all sounds good
then be sure to hit that button and
let's get into it
cross has a very useful quirk known as
shield and this can be used for both
defensive maneuvers like Kirishima or
potentially offensive attacks like
Captain America starting at a basic
level the shield's he produces from his
body are made from thick crust on his
skin and because he can manifest it
anywhere the crust is frequently used to
protect his exposed areas his costume
design seems to be at least partly
inspired by the Spartans and therefore
it leaves quite a bit of his skin
uncovered during battles so this
defensive ability comes in pretty handy
the interesting thing about this quirk
is that it goes beyond just defending
the person who has it as crust can
extend his shields to protect or attack
anyone who's in his general area in the
manga he has a super move called shoot
shield and now this is where he grows a
detachable shield and then throws it
directly at his opponents the character
he used this on was incredibly powerful
so it's definitely not a move you should
underestimate another attacking move
that he has is when he grows these
jagged shields on his forearms and then
digs them into an enemy whilst they're
still digging into that person he then
has the option to instantly grow them to
a ridiculously large size crust has used
these jagged shields to dig into quite a
few people at this point and we've also
seen that he can manifest them just
around his hands instead anyway moving
back to his more defensive moves he can
extend his hands outwards and then
expand his shields to protect anyone
within a reasonable distance I thought
it was a pretty cool design choice like
the way they all connect and as you can
see it all originates from his hand here
if he was to do this with both hands at
the same time I would imagine that he
could create the Great Wall of China but
you know what that's just my opinion
I consider cross quark to be a more
versatile version of Kirishima sand I'll
explain why
looking at their quirks rather than them
as an individual I think shield can do
more things obviously it gives
protection to the user's body as well as
their allies and it also provides attack
options from both close and long range
whereas with hardening although it might
potentially be tougher and like harder
so far it's purely limited to protecting
the user's individual body and also
providing additional damage for close
range attacks so that's why I say cross
quote is a more versatile version
because it can do a lot more but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's better I
mean we still have yet to see her she
miss full potential I would be
interested to know how tough this crust
is versus a care team is unbreakable
form moving on to his personality now
crust is a very empathetic and
passionate character in his first ever
appearance he let the crowd know his
pain and not being able to be there
during all front attack at Camino and he
has tears in his eyes at the fort of
Almighty retirement this shows us many
things I mean the main thing is that
he's not someone who would shy away from
dangerous or life-threatening situations
and he actively beats himself up if he
can't help out his fellow heroes cross
was the only hero that I've known so far
who genuinely actually shows sympathy
for the no move nevertheless he doesn't
let that get in the way of the actual
mission at hand from what I can remember
and I may I may be wrong but from what I
can think of I can't think of another
hero who's ever like made that
connection like oh yeah the gnome who
used to be human I don't like killing
humans so I feel bad killing this no
move like I've never heard another hero
from what I can remember at least going
through that same train of thought based
on that and you know how in tune he is
with his emotions I would definitely
describe him as a chivalrous hero based
on everything we've seen so it's just
one of many reasons why Kirishima should
intern with him make it happen her ago
she make it happen but would that
explained let's move on to part three of
the video where I'll be looking at his
heroic actions during the most recent
arc of the manga so if you don't want to
know any spoilers then this right here
is your 5 second warning during the war
arc there were these six no moves
blocking cross paths and he activates
these jagged shields on the back of his
hands like I mentioned earlier and then
proceeds to butch these guys pretty
quickly but you know six of them six in
a cramped hallway but only a top hero is
dispatching them that
so kudos to crust on that one just a
couple pages later he's already further
down the hallway and comes face to face
with the higher nomu like I said earlier
in the video but with much less detail
when he expanded his shields to attack
this high in nomu look how thick the
shields are in this moment like it's
crazy
time and time again like crust and his
quirk has come in so useful during this
arc and although it Mittal ehi wasn't
able to defeat this no mood we have to
consider the fact that it does have
super heat generation so we've got to
give the guy a break on that one also
when he used the shoot shield attack on
this higher nomu here can we just
appreciate how massive this thing
actually is here is that same gnome
who's standing in front of present Mike
and it's leg alone is the size of two
fully grown men and just for cross to
throw a frisbee made of his skin you
know or as crust is pretty insane
because we haven't seen his no more
sense this is definitely a quirk that
would have required intense training to
get it to where it is today in his days
as a student like I wouldn't really be
surprised if all he could do then was
manifest the crust over his skin in much
the same way that Kirishima is only able
to harden his skin all this other stuff
like the elaborate shields or the Noma
busting attacks like that will probably
came with time and experience which is
one of many reasons why I would love to
see the current class 1-a
as adults like when we can see their
full potential anyway guys that was my
quick video on cross quirk and
personality explained I hope you enjoyed
it and be sure to subscribe as I have a
video I'm planning about my favorite
quirks in the war arc of the manga do be
sure to check that out when it releases
peace out